la gráfica de la función mostrada
continuación
con este valor de entrada para cualquier
de equipos e iguales - de donde vengo
aquí tenemos el ancho de los abanicos del
entradas para funciones sun ex y na
tenemos en las salidas en los valores de la función
él y quería por ejemplo cuando
equivalente y te dio y vallecano
que este valor en cuando es equivalente en el
mínimo 18 cuando ex vale 6 valor y en
vertical de 6 y 5 a 0
entonces cuando este valor de entrada
para cualquier equipo es igual a menos
de la cual tenemos todos los valores de
equipos y en tonos que necesitamos encontrar
un punto en el que ex es igual a menos
que cuando la red y quería tener valor de
menos bueno y vamos a entrar y en tonos
circo izquierda en posición vertical y menos 12
y el costo aquí es en este punto que
corresponder cuando quería mi
valor - 9 cuando usamos menos nueve como
entrada para el rol de equipos chad como este
en qué equipos hay menos nieve
texto